we're here at a beautiful golf course
where I am golfing with an incredible
Chinese diplomat and we're gonna make
such a big deal today hi how are you
Donald Trump a journey to tear yourself
hi how are you she cools okay hello I'm
the vice president Mike I can't shake
your head now my aunt Eckler
wanted it here's Jesus rules okay what's
this guy's name anyway huh Lee Kim Yoon
I'll call you Jimmy
perfect uh Kimmie so are you Jimmy's
daddy I miss translator oh well great
all right Mike you're taking about the
bags Timmy you're with me get in there
it isn't down
just take in English we're gonna nuke
you guys sister yeah nice nice job nice
job good job to replace golf like that
and J's gonna negotiate look at that
right on the green that's a shot so
anyway the purge so incredible one night
a year to get to kill anybody they want
I don't know there's other movies I like
I love Jackie Chan I don't have you been
watching Feud on FX great story about
two elderly women arguing with each
other and they get put to death at the
end which is my favorite part this one
but what he wants to discuss a
chinese-american trade and not movies
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to that but the purge so much fun
I cry at night all the time and I keep
them controllable are you sure you're
negotiating properly we'll get to the
negotiation there we go that's nice
there we go this guy right here
wonder devil what are we going to do
who are we going to bomb first I think
we should talk a little least the whole
thing oh okay as you seriousness as like
would have put a bit of dimpling
we could use there lit up asses and they
guide all the planes in don't you think
that then we drop a mother of all bombs
on North Korea copy well it's so faint
sit we're going to destroy everybody
we're going to kill everybody don't
worry we're going to kill everyone will
kill everyone's families Wow I got it on
yes if it get that Stepan don't shake
hands if it did you see that's never how
you do that's never there
you always always have to put your mouth
on it and then he shoot yours
you shoot you smell nice
oh my god that was awful
Mike get the ball he said he would love
to talk about guilt yeah we're as you
know we're totally gonna talk about
meals it's gonna be great
look at the geese don't you get you kids
to read those we really he's wonderful
it all comes down to this the Chinese
diplomat and I have spent a rigorous 18
holes negotiating Chinese American trade
relation and we've made an incredible
bet if I sink this putt then I get
everything I want and if we don't the
Chinese go home and I'm left
empty-handed but I think I've got this
one in the bag they get ready to pay up
that's step nice doing business with you
mr. don't do it Mike don't talk to me
excuse me excuse me
we finished the deal totally and
completely in the favor of the United
States please you can't leave Yemen we
can't leave I need a deal
the Chinese diplomat melted like butter
in the Sun I mean this guy was on his
knees please God please please on to
whatever you want every Chinese just in
your lockup I don't care have another
Chairman square you can have another
German square I drove them so hard by
the end we got everything we wanted and
more I get money I got money on me I
think I have money I don't have any
money on me I've got a tongue like a
little turtle that's stuck it up on and
it won't come all the way out and women
say they love that I just wanted to make
a deal
you did great America's great again
America is totally great again